was good so you're texting yourself
whoever said that yes yes oh my gosh
well thank you for joining in you could
team up and you know secede from the
[Laughter]
room let's suggestion number one is
coming from you what's it going to be
Harry Potter Harry Potter feels like a
Heckle
[Applause]
madam what um what aspect of Harry
Potter would you like us to focus upon
she doesn't even know it she doesn't
even know okay cool are you too good for
Harry Potter
I couldn't read you just couldn't read
you couldn't
read where did you grab up when where
did you grab up uh North Carolina North
Carolina tracks um no it doesn't it's
lovely it's love it's a lovely Place see
South Carolina would have got a much
bigger pop but North Carolina's actually
quite cultured apologies to any South
Carolinians in here um Charlotte
Asheville whereabouts in North Carolina
oh rally rally yeah [__] I I did a
show that about three months ago so yeah
you didn't need to bother to come to New
York
got lovely stuff okay so growing up in
North Carolina not being able to read
and enjoying Harry Potter it's
suggestion number one this don't worry
if you give a suggestion I'm not going
to get into your backstory and biography
what would you like a wrap about over
here Pinocchio Pinocchio are you you a
fan of the the classic tale or the
Disney adaptation adaptation the
adaptation okay did you know it was a
story before Walt Disney yeah yeah
um Pinocchio cool uh can I get an
activity just like a thing you might
Tinder Tinder cool Pinocchio on Tinder
that's what we're doing middle just to
make it more fun more spicy it's a
Friday middle of the room what you like
a wrap About Cats the musical cat's the
musical thank you for clarifying because
you know I said no animals and you were
like I'm going to get you with this one
cuz technically it is a work of fiction
and it's a terrible [__] thing
written by an idiot isn't
it cuz the poems is based on really good
and then Andrew lyd Weber
like [__] musical
toad look did I maybe audition for Andre
we play and not get it maybe that
happened
but what did you say you said Jewish
what Jewish tunnel oh the Jewish tunnels
yeah oh gosh it was quite cuz it's it's
quite a fun news story but it's quite
hard to bring it up to people isn't it
cuz you like you see someone you're like
have you heard about the Jewish tunnels
and they're like oh [__] you're not one
of them are
you they operate the space lasers
from if you don't know under the the did
you pronounce it kabad the under like
one of the very Orthodox synagogues they
dug like 150 M long tunnel that came out
in a a bath house didn't it it was from
the the Jewish bath house into the
synagogue I don't know why but you know
fun
great great so cat's the musical Jewish
tunnels growing up not being able to
read but loving Harry Potter in North
Carolina and Pinocchio on Tinder well so
far that's four I mean this side you
been left with one but I'm sure it's
going
okay I feel like you thought everyone
was going to be with you
there um are are you a Texan yourself I
am but I live in the village is that
does that make me
better I don't I don't
know feel like it's like you know I
murdered a man but now work with
charities does that may
me um I suppose it does what what do you
miss the most about Texas living here in
New York
tacos
you're
excellent male ventriloquism there
Madam you miss Texan tacos and you can't
there's plenty of taco trucks around
here okay okay but not as good so you're
texting yourself whoever said that yes
yes oh my gosh well thank you for
joining in you could team up and you
know secede from the
room Let's uh let's do this Gina let's
let's drop that beat this is a freestyle
based on all those suggestions not
written not prep not re it's going to be
really really exciting we'll start with
the least exciting suggestion which is
Texas don't worry and we'll take it step
by step from there what type of tacos is
your favorite sir Alor al
pastor I asked his favorite type maybe
that's a mistake I'll Pastor I presume
that's the Shaving of steak you put it
there on the spit spinning round and
round I like my beef from the cab when
it's ground or maybe the langa yo that's
the tongue do the little Spanish Binga
never wrong but I check first when I'm
in Texas when I go I'm like Su bro I
need a tacle from down
south Chipotle that's my nice order I'll
be eating all the stuff ye I'm in the
East vage is the best by far I miss that
hey best of friends I love the food but
I really hate Mexicans they come
old Grand bab I say no please lock him
away we got to send him down but you're
in a good town moving from Texas I'm
looking around you want to talk about
cats the musical to make me watch that
is abusing you all I'm just sat there
like Jesus Christ a gravity I can't
believe the cats oh yes it's macavity
and jelal and all the stuff I don't
really care and when they put it on the
big screen up there they had to CG the
bum holes they would disappear that was
upsetting I want to see there real I
want to see it twinkle it's shameful but
they took away their aim as painful for
me to talk about this yeah I know it's
so clever going help Lea [__] that Andre
Lloyd we he's a f guy what a terrible
mistake if you want to go to
Williamsburg take care you see guys with
the ringlets of the hair and the Big
Wide brim hat hanging around there
they're like okay you want to have fun
yall Orthodox Jews coming down in the
tunnel deep below we follow schneerson
that fellow the rabbi rip died in 94 but
he was down there like dig more and
more put it there yes I don't understand
a permit what's that I'll dig with my
Spade just keep going for days and days
it's what we need to do yeah we're going
to dash out coming from the synagogue
there into the bath house that's okay I
know you're feeling right you're there
with your little reading light looking
down a book saying what am I after I
don't understand what is a chapter what
is a s
what is a word what is an headward a
bird that be the whole
thing North Carolina they're on your own
in rally they should have rallied to
your cause like don't worry you're going
to win this war and J R read the audio
book you'd love it maybe when you read
it when you have a look just listen to
the one narrated by Steven fry he's a
very intelligent aidite British guy and
if you do that face it you could switch
the wizard book for something more basic
just sit down and watch watch an
animated show this one you know is
Pinocchio yeah he's going to pluck it
the courage up this guy a tiny little
puppet wants to be a real boy so he can
go out into the world and get some you
know
vagina dick he's like oh yeah you know
she's going to get he goes there uses
his nose not his finger and starts
swiping so frustrated he wants to set
him straight he's like jetto can I go up
on a date I met a really nice girl I'm
going to do a good I'll give it to a why
cuz I've got a lot of
wood very you
guys that's how you CL out